hey guys welcome back to packet X today
I'm working on a pretty complex building
for the log flume to go through as well
as a string of facades alongside the
lake here and also a small transition
part into the Japanese area though I'm
gonna save the making of the Japanese
area itself for the next episode or
episodes probably and it might also take
quite a while before I actually get that
done but the Roman area is more or less
finished at this stage and I just sort
of need to get into the foliage around
this section of the park and the park in
general at some point in the future but
that's just something I want to avoid
for the time being
so I'll just focus on the scenery and
the buildings just around this lake so
the first thing I wanted to work on is
the awkward I wouldn't really know what
to call it it's sort of like a compound
building with lots of different small
facades over here the idea is very
escaped from Pompeii ish in concepts
there's this big almost mountain like
creation of buildings which the log
flume goes through and the lift Hills go
up too and you eventually have these
drops which come out of these buildings
and are like the central points of this
lake here and in that sense it's really
similar to escape from Pompeii but I
wanted to do something slightly
different in this case because that ride
has a very flat sort of simple facade
and it's also really made as if it were
like the ruins of Pompeii so it's
definitely really toughest devastated
and kind of like a rubble and I wanted
to make this look a little bit more
clean almost like it's a sort of village
that's placed alongside a cliff face and
very compact and on different levels
just to make it look a bit more
interesting and more alive than the real
dead facades of escape from Pompeii and
it's also pretty helpful in the general
sense of force perspective I feel in
this building which is one of the most
important things in how this general
area is laid out and what's really
central to the idea of the log flume
although it's not very original it's
something that is very common in log
flumes but the the central idea is
really that you have this large building
over here which is behind the
to have that force perspective of having
it further away from any other buildings
so it really stands on it on its own
making it look a little bit bigger than
it actually is which is reinforced by
having the log flumes come out of the
building just making it look even taller
than it really is and also making the
drops of the log flume look a bit bigger
and I wanted to also play with that by
making the buildings just a string of
very small parts and looks that would
stick out and yeah just loads of
different smaller pieces and parts of
the building in general just to make it
look a little bit bigger and interesting
than just one simple facade and its
really a stacked kind of city in that
sense and there isn't really much over
thought behind all of the buildings
which I built it was just generally the
general idea of having all of these
small parts over here and sort of stack
them up until it turned into a hill of a
building and really just go with that as
a general plan and just make every
single part of the building a little bit
different much like the rest of the
buildings in the Roman area but it's
there is no real central planning or
plan behind it I just wanted to get a
general shape and the details of the
building don't even matter that much I
would say though as I would always like
to do there is that one sort of
signature part of the building I wanted
to have one part which would just be the
biggest parts and really give an idea of
what the building looks like in general
so that's why I made the part where the
largest drop comes out a little bit
larger and very similar to the temples
in Rome just to make that sort of like
these signature parts and the most
iconic part of the building just to give
it I would say a bit of an identity but
that's perhaps not the right word for it
just to make it to give the building
some sort of form which is recognizable
instead of just being one big blob of
small parts where you can't really make
out any sort of central thing to it so
yeah that was a general idea but as soon
as that was done I just started adding
these little bits and bobs all around
the place and just made all of these
little building blobs to make sure that
the general shape of the building was
all done it's also a bit more
interesting with have
like all of the different parts of the
buildings and different heights and
different levels I sort of hang over
each other and having the log flume go
through it as like a lot of interaction
between the building parts and the log
flume kind of just going through each
other it's very like an integrating kind
of way which yeah that's just the
general idea behind the building I might
in hindsight have switched up the style
a little bit more like in the nd Roman
area did turn out to be very similar
install there isn't as much of a
difference in terms of roof colors or
details I also feel it might be a bit
washed out so I may return to that as in
the colors are quite washed out but then
again I also wanted to get that sort of
idea because it's just the general sort
of aesthetic of Roman buildings hence
also why I wanted to go with all of
these sort of beige colors but give all
the different parts of the buildings
slightly different beige colors or
sometimes even some shades of white ish
colors but still keep the the very small
trims and borders as ways to add some
extra accents and extra contrasting
colors to the buildings as opposed to
just having white walls and just leaving
it at that
I also decided to actually make the
rockwork a bit more interesting than
what I had in the rest of the park so
far so it's also something that I might
want to return to in the rest of the
park as well because there's quite a lot
of smaller pebbles and stuff like that
in this Rock work so I might want to add
some extra detail to the existing rock
work what I didn't want to do though is
add water lilies to this point of the
lake since it's just the a lake with a
log flume all over the lake and I'm not
entirely sure but I am quite sure that
water lilies wouldn't really work out
well in this case not to mention that in
a in a body of water which isn't moving
as soon as you have water lilies that
sort of like all over the place they
don't really sit in one corner but if
you add them you kind of need to add
them everywhere and it's just something
that doesn't really work well with the
log flume it's not something I kind of
missed out on and with having all of the
rock work and all of the buildings and
on the sides of the lake I also couldn't
really get too many bowl rushes in and
it was hard to get in
a foliage but I still wanted to keep
some foliage like these small bushes and
trees here in there to add a bit of
greenery to this general area because I
was quite afraid that if I didn't add it
it would just become one big massive
slab of concrete and bricks and that's
something I didn't want to quite have I
wanted to make it look a little bit more
natural than that
not to mention that tsipras's are
probably a really easy and good way to
make anything look Mediterranean I guess
as long as you just keep slapping
tsipras's in a certain area it's gonna
look somewhat Mediterranean at least so
yeah that's why I also wanted to go
ahead and do that now over here on this
side of the lake is the sort of I would
say put a Ventura ish inspired part of
the park though it wasn't much except
for just looking up the portal material
facades thinking yep I could go for
something like that getting into the
game and just building parts at random
it's it's again not something that I
planned at all and really just like I
didn't even plan the the building shapes
or anything even slightly I had you just
kind of go along as you build and it's
pretty easy to do you don't really need
to think about anything that you're
really doing and generally if you bump
into something which doesn't look as
good you just remove it and move on and
it's a lot of fun to work that way it's
not really the most effective way and
it's definitely not the best for perhaps
making the best looking things but it is
just a lot of fun and it's pretty fast
as well so that's why I wanted to go for
that approach over here not to mention
that these are pretty simple buildings
like these are not any of the big
weenies or the main centres of attention
in the theme park so they're just sort
of side buildings so I didn't really
care for them that's much so this
approach really worked without for these
buildings as long as the facade sort of
is dynamic in the end so there are loads
of different pieces to look at and the
buildings aren't quite as straight and
rectangular or predictable but it's more
or less almost the very organic mass of
buildings I also had to quickly delete
that part of the building though I did
have some bigger plans with that
building but I completely forgot about
the
the suspended monorail its that didn't
quite work out it's so I can't really
extend it beyond that so I think in the
future I'll actually connect that path
in the corner there to the Japanese area
but I also wanted to have another
connection to the Japanese area to make
this facade over here a little bit more
interesting than just one string of
straight buildings so by having this
little path I wanted to make a small set
of towers and a large arch just to have
that sort of building go over the path
and not just have these same buildings
in this string of facades so it's kind
of interesting because it it was also a
way to get a more castle ish Roman peace
of building if I could call it that in
this part of the of the Roman area
because it's not really very typical of
the Roman themes in general but rome did
have some city walls and of course Roman
cities also had city walls and it's
something which I didn't really have yet
and I figured I might as well make this
look a bit more atmospheric and Roman
like by having a small sort of city war
gates over here which just seemed like
not just fun to build but also quite
practical and that it was just another
entrance into the Japanese area in case
the Japanese area gets a lot of
attention and many people want to go
there from here it could realistically
also handle quite some larger crowds and
the other path that is sort of
pointlessly going over the lake it's
just purely for cosmetic reasons I just
felt like having a small pier stick out
from the the large halo of buildings
which the log flume goes into and it
would be quite nice to have that small
path go underneath the log flumes where
you can just walk to kind of watch the
log flumes and just kind of watch that
happen if you're like me and you don't
even dare to ride a log flumes
so yeah that's something I wanted to get
in there like that and here I dipped
into another little activity one thing
which I really wanted to do and I've
said this in the last episode as well is
actually add some hills to the park
because it's called Cydonia hills so it
better damn well have some hills too -
actually I live up to its name
I guess so wanted to have some
quick hills but it doesn't just work
better for the park reasons one of the
reasons why I felt the park just felt
really empty on the outside like
obviously it is gonna be empty because I
won't add anything outside the park
really but it really felt so empty and
propensity Vande predictable so I wanted
to add some hills instead of just making
it flats and add some more foliage on
top of that to see how it would work and
it's very heavily inspired by the like
the general areas around the roller
coaster curtain one scenarios especially
Hills that you would see in Diamond
Heights or Katie's world scenarios like
that if anybody remembers them like
you'd always have this small park which
is like one small part of the map and
the entire map would always be filled
with all of these gridded hills because
that's how the hills and rollercoaster
qn1 worked as well with just random
foliage on it and maybe some scenery
here and there and that's something I
wanted to have for this park as well
because I won't really get into a
realistic surrounding with parking lots
or backstage spaces like the huge holes
or yeah some sort of backstage buildings
that you usually see in theme parks and
instead wanted to have that sort of
rollercoaster cone one approach to the
outside of the park where you feel like
you're part like the pot like the park
is located in some sort of world but
aside from that it's it's pretty
standard and anonymous but still one of
fun things to look at properly so yeah
moving on I wanted to make a quick
transition area into the Japanese area I
wasn't actually quite sure how I wanted
to do this at first so just figured Yolo
I'm gonna go for something make that
quick little square which is actually
pretty nice and works out pretty well in
the end just to connect those two paths
together before they go underneath a can
I spoil all this yet I probably can
before they go underneath a torii gates
like one of these typical Japanese gates
and you actually transition into the
Japanese area properly so this is sort
of like a general transition area where
nothing interesting is happening no real
rights some simple buildings and just a
bit of foliage just to make sure that
the transition isn't suddenly you're in
Rome and suddenly you're in Japan but
there's that there is sort of a little
more gradual thing and obviously I
wanted to create a simple connection
between the the alpine area and the
Japanese area as well so you can sort of
use this path over here to skip over the
Roman area if you're not into Roman
areas and just go straight to the
Japanese area which you can do another
part of the park as well but that's
quite a bit further away from this part
so I figured it would be nice to add
that quick shortcut over here as well
and it's well truth be told it's also a
pretty good way to fill in this empty
space I don't want to have too much
empty spaces like a little bit of
greenery and Foresti for history and
butchery and shrubbery in some general
areas of the park is okay but I don't
know like make two large areas just
completely open especially given that
the map size isn't really big and I
still have quite some sizable plans for
the future I do want to keep it open a
little bit okay so this is where I then
tried to make a torii gates or perhaps I
should say torii but actually pretty
miserably failed a couple of times at
first because the horizontal pieces that
I wanted to use are obviously all just
well they're all tied to the grid so I
can't really make anything of them but
just place them exactly on the grid
which was kind of annoying because I
wanted to actually go off grid a little
bit there and I was hoping to be able to
get a 2 square wide part underneath this
thing to have it connect very neatly to
the gate itself which turned out to be
impossible so instead had to have this
one tile part go underneath it sort of
use the pillars to make this gate seem a
little bit more offsets than it actually
is and have some small pots around it
just to make sure that it can actually
deal with all the people that might want
to go into the Japanese area because
obviously a 1 square pot is pretty small
and in general it also keeps the it also
helps to keep the general area around
the gates a little bit more open and
allows for some small gardens around
them around the gates just to make the
gates a little bit more visible and more
like it's proper parts of scenery and
more like it's a proper transition into
the Japanese area as well
so that's why I wanted to
this way I don't actually have any plans
for the Japanese area specifically
though but with every time I talk about
this I'm increasingly sure that I want
to make a BM inverts so I'll probably
get into that but the Japanese style
itself is something that I still need to
play around with a bit more because I'm
not quite sure how I'm going to actually
tackle it at the moment because I just
haven't really tried it yet so I still
want to make a couple of test buildings
and after that hopefully I might have
enough courage to start work on the
Japanese area but at the moment I am not
quite sure how it's gonna exactly work
out so I don't need to procrastinate a
little bit and work on some other stuff
that I kind of want to do as well but
yeah that is right about it for this
episode thank you guys for watching and
I hope to see you guys next time